hi everybody I'm Nancy O'Dell bringing
you the et interview breakdown free of
Juan Pablos worst offensive um I guess
three things that stood out to me this
season with Juan Pablo the first time I
guess I noticed he was having trouble or
struggling he kind of letting go and
embracing the whole concept was in
Vietnam with Clare in the whole ocean
thing and that's where I kind of
realized he was kind of serving two
masters of trying to be a dad and be
respectful yet trying to embrace and let
go and be the bachelor and then I guess
you know it probably involves Clare
again you know in that the helicopter
and I don't know what was said but
something that really offended her he
had this moment to be sweet and genuine
and share something off camera off mic
and instead he took that time to say
something that apparently really upset
her I guess last night after the final
Rose it was a little unsatisfying only
because the in goal of our show is to
end up with a couple and I felt like wow
we we actually out of all of this we did
it we have a couple who loves each other
Nikki loves him and I think he loves her
but he just wouldn't give in any just
won't and I don't know why I don't know
where the anger or angst or reservations
come from I don't know Nikki said she
loves them and wants to have this
relationship wants to go on it I mean
she was actually ready to accept a
proposal so obviously she loves him I
think if I were a betting man not only
does he love her but he tells her why he
didn't want to share that with the world
I have no idea I don't dislike him I'm
not angry I mean I don't gain really
anything from love or him not saying
love admit it meant nothing to me so I
was just trying to kind of help him
articulate and show some emotion because
I think that would have been a long way
for our fans who signed up to watch this
he really tried to control the situation
and it's a situation you cannot control
to have it work you really have to give
yourself up to this thing and give
yourself to us and kind of trust and
that's a scary vulnerable place to be
he couldn't get there and from the
beginning he you know tried to sneak his
first kiss with Clare off camera he did
sneak his first kiss with Nikki off
camera he would try and say things and
do things off camera and
it was like well if you're that worried
about why are you doing this
honestly overall and it's my sound weird
but I'm not disappointed I'm not mad I I
love this show for all the reasons that
you saw last night
and all the reasons that you saw at Sean
and Catherine's wedding it can in like
that or it can in like it did last night
confusing and unsatisfied and bizarre
and because that's how relationships are
it's how love is